we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
trumpet commending my integrity take a
listen to this hi my name is robert Noah
I'm a supporting Republican I just want
to call I called you about a week ago
and I discussed with your thoughts on
the antifa member who attacked the ice
facility was and I saw that you covered
in your show today I just look like you
know even though I probably disagree
with you on 90% of policy issues I think
you're a man of integrity and I really
appreciate the fact that you covered
this even if you put your own spin on it
that shows to me you're denouncing or
violence and your willingness to cover
it is a really amazing thing and I think
you represent that you could disagree
with someone but you still could have
integrity and still learn a lot of
things from each other so I'd love to
talk to you in person or on your show
but I keep up the good work and even
though I disagree with job still be
listen thanks a lot thank you so much
the by the way that was also Gavin
McInnes I'm kidding yeah i i'm not i'm
not afraid of covering these stories
like the one that's referenced there
because i know that we have the
principles on our side and we have the
facts on our side and i am NOT going to
occult or hide anything from you on the
basis of trying to create a particular
picture as i've said historically i've
self-censored because i just don't want
to hit certain Hornets nests with a
stick sometimes for my own personal
sanity but i appreciate the comment and
i will keep calling it the way I see it
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we will talk about a judge
dismissing the lawsuit from one of those
teenagers from the maggot at Washington
DC fiasco of a few months back we will
talk about whether 10,000 steps a day
really is a requirement for health and
much much more I have one of those
fitness trackers and I'll tell you what
my step goal is every day there's a
closely guarded secret but I will reveal
it on today's bonus show get access to
the bonus show by becoming either a
member or a patron I'll speak to you
then